i'm not that person y'all trying to make
me out to be i'm not that person
i'm not this whole gorilla glue girl my
name is tessica brown
call me i'll talk to you i'll let you
know exactly who i am
jessica i mean i see it in your face
right now i know you have a lot of
emotions going on
how are you first and foremost how are
you feeling
um i'm almost i'm over it
i'm over it yeah so
we see your the current status of your
hair right now
you went to the emergency room what
exactly did they give you and is it
helping at all
well when i went there they took me
straight to the back for one she started
using a little um
acetone effects yeah and she started
getting it from the back
but as she's getting it it's burning so
they have the sailing water
trying to cool it as she was going but
it was burning to the point where
my heart was beating to the face so we
would stop
she would go again we would stop and
she's telling me tesla if we get this
out of here
we gonna be here for at least 20 hours
so i
asked her what could is it possible that
i can go home
and let my mom and my sisters do it at
least you know i can be
home because i do have three children
that have to come three little girls
that i have to come home to so i mean
and now people are saying
oh she should have stood in the hospital
for those 20 hours
yeah yeah and i want to talk to you
about that
about the opinions and how you're
dealing with that because i know it's a
lot on you
on top of what you're already struggling
with um but before we get to that
can you walk us through the moment this
happened a month ago
when you ran out of hairspray can you
walk us through that moment
well i was going somewhere and my oldest
son he had my car
so when i went to go use my spray
it didn't have anymore so i'm like you
know that was the closest thing to it
and soon as i get home i could wash it
right out but when
i got home it didn't wash out see that
was my major question
were you in a rush to go somewhere you
know i mean i'm a woman
too and i like my hair right but if i
don't have a product i'll just wait but
it seems as if you were
in a rush have you ever used gorilla
glue before
yeah i used it before and it worked
pretty good so you used it on your hair
before
no no no no no no okay like i've used it
on like for christmas
i've used it so at what point did you
realize that
it was a major problem was it when you
got home and you tried to wash it out
well no it was like i'm gonna say the
week later and i had to call my mama
like my
this is not coming out this this is not
coming out so we started using all kind
of overuse
olive oil cooking oil uh
tea tree we was using pretty much any
old so that's
on the video it was so so shiny yeah
yeah but then
everybody started you know the reason i
went to the internet
because i never was gonna take the
social media the reason i took it to
social media because
i i didn't know what else to do and i
know somebody out there could have told
me something
yeah i didn't think for one second when
i got up the next morning
it was gonna be everywhere how are you
dealing with that
because of course there are opinions you
have people throwing shade but you have
also a lot of people showing support and
love yeah
so emotionally how are you dealing with
all those opinions i'm usually the
person that
i don't care you know what people say
you know i just
move at my own pace you know i don't
care what people say
but it's just getting to the point where
you know people are on tv
saying stuff about me you don't even
know me
like if you knew me
you wouldn't you would you wouldn't say
have to stop you're saying if they knew
me
and you reached out for help it wasn't
me
it was for advice again it never was
for this then somebody said oh well she
spread it in my head
um on purpose just to get to here
who in their right mind would it just
say oh well let me just spray this in my
head and
you know i'm gonna become famous
overnight never
listen and the inside of my head is like
you know little radiance just
who would want that who would want that
i needed somebody to tell me how to take
this home
that's all it was do you regret posting
it
definitely wow definitely definitely i
told my
i told my son today i wish i could just
i mean
go back yeah because i'm i'm over it i'm
over
i'm over it is shaving your hair an
option or shaving your head an option or
is that well when
we tried to do the razor we could like
when we did the um acid
it was like you could have got under
here um
but then we couldn't get to the other
spots
but last night i ended up cutting my
ponytail oh
i mean everybody knows the breed never
was mine but my opponent
itself we cut it off last night so in
the middle
you can still feel my hair it's just all
around
and then we started with the um the
i forgot the name of the stuff we
started with that
that no um
i didn't say the name because i feel
like they're gonna make that a big name
okay yeah so we started with that
and as we're doing it in the front
the baby bangs that i had yeah just
started coming
off like oh yeah if
i mean i don't do it on here but if you
i can pretty much white because i'll put
some
stuff on it just make it look like it's
black yeah okay okay
yeah wow so so your hair is falling out
there
yes other than the fact that you should
never use gorilla glue in your hair
again
what is this teaching you what do you
think
i'm pretty much yeah just don't use it
yeah don't use it
yeah because i know and don't post it
true true i know for me i've i had to
learn a lot of hard lessons when it
comes to
all the extremes i would go to for
beauty you know
like because girl you see my edges too
like i like my hair to be laid
and as black women we have our tricks
you know our things we do here and there
um but do you think you're at a point
now where
you're thinking about the extreme length
you went to
to to get this style perfect have you
thought about that
like maybe reconsidering that i should
have just put a hat on
so is your hair is it loosening up at
all or
it is but it's it's like i told it's
taking a minute
only because the stuff that we're using
it's burning
yeah like it's burning
are you feeling anything physically like
did the doctor say that this
can't hurt you anyway as far as like i
get it
extreme headache and he said by the time
i get it all out or cut it all off i
may have scalp damage and in some parts
my hair might not even grow back
all right well let's talk about the love
that's being sent your way
a lot of celebrities chance the rapper
being one of them he's saying that
he's glad people are supporting you has
there been anyone else who reached out
to you
that we may know of offering any
assistance and if so
how are they trying to help portia
mm-hmm
yeah porsha wants to send me here just
hilarious i mean
me and i talk every day like you know
like we're friends wow
yeah like we're really friends who else
it's it's a lot of
it's a lot a lot of people i can tell
you one person i saw beyonce's longtime
hairstylist neil
he offered you a wig and girl that's
something i said
look he does beyonce's hair so are you
going to take him up on that offer
that's a silver lining in this whole
situation that's one at least
listen but i'm telling you it's a lot of
people that want to give me hair
but the reason i wasn't accepting it
because i don't want people to be like
oh that's why she didn't and i totally
get that in the social media
world that you know we have to deal with
at the same time girl you're going
through some
some some struggles and you have people
offering assistance so
if you want it i say this is just my
advice
don't allow that to stop you from
getting your blessings because that's a
blessing
and there are a number of blessings
coming your way um i want to talk about
the gorilla glue statement that they
released they said that they sympathize
with what you're going through
but they also made it clear that on the
warning label it says not to get
the glue in your skin on your skin or in
your eyes or clothing
what did you think of their response i
made a mistake i mean i
okay yeah i mean i don't know yeah
so there there were some reports or
according to tmz
you hired attorney and are weighing your
legal options against gorilla glue is
that true
no i i know i've never ever seen that
wow
yeah i mean again i don't know where all
of this is coming from because at this
point
everybody's saying it like girl
yeah my heart goes out to you right now
you also launched a gofundme account a
lot of people are helping um you've
already raised over 12 000
for people who want to help what exactly
is the money
going towards well the
wigs that everybody's telling me i'm
need that's why i only said
you know fifteen hundred dollars yeah
but
from us reading about everything that's
pretty much
probably about the goal of my head and
already done start happening
after the hair situation is fixed
you now have people that are interested
in you
you know you have what you've gained
over 530
000 followers in just a week you're
verified on instagram now
and i know all of that really means
nothing compared to what you're going
through
but you do somewhat have um
a platform now do you have you been
thinking about ways to use
that or after all of the situation is
handled
um no like again in my inbox
it's a lot of people please do promos
please do foremost again
i don't do none of that because i feel
like they're gonna say this is why she
did this
well i'll tell you this from listening
for you right now
i clearly see where your heart is and if
anybody watches this and still think
that you did this for clout or whatever
that's their issue and it's obviously
not the truth
look like every time somebody put
something on social media
that's it my inbox flood um
don't worry about what they're saying
yeah you know
y'all can say that y'all can say that
but this my mama keeps telling me
you know stop reading the comments yeah
yeah but look
i can't help myself i go read them it's
way way way
too much way too much